hey y'all it's andrew couch here and
this is how you choose a video we're not
going to be going over this week's data
set
instead uh my channel just reached a
milestone of a thousand subscribers
so i figured i'd make a video on my
youtube channel itself
and this isn't going to be a lot of
there isn't going to be any coding
because
uh frankly uh youtube has a pretty good
analytics
um dashboard so i figured i could just
go over
my youtube analytics and go through some
you know some basic
uh kind of like uh internet based um
analytic metrics such as like
click-through rates etc
and we could just analyze my own uh
youtube videos because i think most
channels
or it's very hard to find um someone
really showing
of their own analytics and since my
channel has gotten to be
not necessarily a large channel but it
has
you know a decent amount of subscribers
can tear compared to the average channel
i thought it'd be interesting to go over
it so this isn't gonna be doing any r
stuff but i figured as a gift for
hitting a thousand subscribers
i would basically release uh my entire
analytics data and put it on github so
you guys could look over it uh yourself
so this is the actual dashboard um for
our
for uh or a youtube studio
um and one of the things i look at uh
when i actually go over my youtube
analytics which is actually very rarely
because frankly i i don't really spend
that much time for
growth of my channel i mostly just focus
on what my commenters
say or what series i'm trying to do so
if we look at my actual videos
um we can see it we have my videos i
have you know your
basic summaries of like views comments
likes and dislikes
um so for my videos i generally go
through
a certain theme for like a month so my
past few videos have been focusing more
on
dashboards and also uh on like uh
was it neural networks so let's actually
go to my analytics page
and see some of the basic summaries of
my youtube analytics
so generally what they'll do is they'll
give you like your month over month
analytics
so compared in the last 28 days uh
i'm up compared to my last month so in
so basically i've been increasing by a
thousand views um
my watch time has increased and my
subscribers are about the same
so one of the things i was doing for
this channel was i really wanted to
optimize
based off of watch time um i i post
uh not very frequently so it's only
weekly a one weekly video
so um i didn't really care a lot about
views um because especially since this
topic
of like you know teaching data science
using r
is a pretty niche concept i wanted to
focus on basically having videos that
were
watched and consumed a lot so i was
focusing mostly on watch time
um obviously i think subscribers is just
a good thing to
try to optimize too but it wasn't
necessarily something i wanted to focus
on so i was really looking at like you
know um what my commerce wanted
to what wanted me to make so if i saw a
comment that i thought i could easily
make a video on it i would
generally do it um so let's actually
scroll down
and this is my top videos so they'll
give you top videos
again none of this is that you know
complicated but it's certainly pretty
interesting that they have this
analytics
um that's really easy uh understandable
and it's pretty much uh for how how
little
like small amount of samples or the um
little videos i have is not a lot so
just having these like basic summary
statistics of
my videos and on my channel is very
valuable
i wouldn't expect to actually do a lot
of like data sciences stuff
for a very small channel with not a lot
of videos posted
instead i would probably focus more on
these like very high level
metrics i think data science could
definitely be applied to like a website
where you had a
decent amount of traffic or a december
products to look at but
for a simple youtube channel i think it
doesn't make any sense and the general
inferences you can have from it
is not great so we're actually gonna
go over these videos i was surprised
probably the most is
if i'm looking at my top was it five
videos for the past
month um i think there's a certain theme
um which i thought was kind of
interesting where basically my most
viewed videos
are around dashboarding um this channel
really has not been that heavily focused
on dashboards it's
mostly focused on like machine learning
and tidying models
so when i saw that i think that when i
saw this
you know top videos in this period i
think it makes sense too because
generally i think people like making
dashboards so
dashboards are pretty easy to dip your
toes into you don't need to know a lot
of knowledge of like
data wrangling or data cleaning or any
type of statistical framework
uh so i think getting into dashboards is
very easy and very fun to
to do actually and which which is what i
did too when i got into
like data science or data in general was
was create little plots and create
dashboards and like tableau and
excel and stuff like that so these are
the top 10 videos um
again pretty straightforward i when i
generally upload videos i have a good
kind of like gut feeling of what i would
expect it to get so
uh for example when i posted my beginner
to advanced dashboards
video or my previous week's dashboard
video
i knew it was going to get a decent
amount of views because i know that
people from different um you know
some different backgrounds so some
people are beginners some people are
advanced
um then they still want to learn are
shiny because there's not a ton of
resources on our shiny
um so i knew that video was going to get
a decent attraction
because i knew from beforehand my ufc
dash for video gets a decent amount of
views
uh views constantly or consistently
so something that when i was looking at
i knew um that was going to get a decent
reviews
um again so what's cool too about this
um
little um interface is we have like um
the
little what is a little uh point where
we actually uploaded a video and you can
kind of see
a spike of increase in views you know an
increase of watch times and then we can
see how
you know you have this like seasonal
trend of subscribers where you know
generally when i
gain subscribers it's when i post a
video um from new people looking at it
so one of the things that we can start
looking at is like reach
um so this is all about like impressions
click through
uh views unique viewers etc
so impressions is only just them showing
you
uh showing a user or i guess a person on
a youtube my video so it's been shown so
about 61 000
saw like the thumbnail to my video
somewhere so i got recommend them
recommended to them like on a front page
but only about four percent of these
people
ended up clicking on the video right so
that's not great
i would say um my click-through rate my
impressions are click-through rate
is actually down 10 and that could be
just a function of one
uh the topics might not be as
interesting or two
it could just not be it could be because
the the thumbnail of the actual video
isn't that appealing so you know i think
generally people like
is like um very flashy thumbnails so
i think uh a good rule to do is
basically choose a plot that's very
colorful
as your front uh thumbnail
so yeah we can see my click-through rate
it's it's down a little bit but to be
honest it's pretty
um you know the average is probably
about four percent right
so views per impression shown or how
many viewers watch the video after
seeing an impression
okay and again my view my views have
been
pretty stagnant i guess uh pretty i get
pretty consistent views throughout
the the days and then unique viewers
it's something where i
i'm not sure if i'm really that worried
about um for unique viewers
um so that's not that interesting right
now you can also get traffic sources
so most of it's called browse features
um and this
is a little bit different so this is
like home screen subscriptions
and you know just like the front page so
sometimes when you're looking at videos
they'll have like recommended stuff
sometimes it'll be subscribers um so i
would expect you know the majority
of my um viewers or traffic is gonna
come from a subscription or
recommendations
the second is the actual youtube search
uh which i thought was a little
interesting just because it's talking
more about how like
you know someone's gonna be searching
like our shiny dashboards on youtube
uh and they and then they're gonna find
my videos and click on it so
to be honest i i didn't really expect
that high of a percentage i thought most
people would either just have it as
recommended
um i think also just learning r from
videos is
that i personally don't like at all even
though i make videos on our
a teaching r in in a video format i
personally just prefer
um textbooks so i'm not really a good
you know
source for understanding what people
want to look at
for or what people want to search when
they're looking up stuff to learn from r
and then from channel pages i don't i
guess from like other channels
stuff like that topic channel pages um
not nothing too crazy
i think the suggested video is pretty
good too
um because i add a lot of cards to my um
videos at the end so
always offer a suggested um video from
my
i think my tuesday playlist so again
this is it's pretty interesting um we
can go a little bit deeper
i'm just gonna i'm just going over the
high level um interfaces
or my analytics page but then we'll
start going into the actual
you know crosstabs of the data so
here's the actual impressions of watch
time so you can see like um
you know it's shown to 61 000 people
right 37.2 from youtube recommending
your content
i think is a little interesting so i
guess youtube is actually recommending
my content 37
time the other is just other stuff um so
maybe i would like to actually increase
that so
make sure so somehow i could just change
it where
you know youtube was recommended my
content forty percent of time right
so out of those sixty one thousand
people uh four percent clicked on it and
then we have those views from
um the click through rate and then from
those views um they're averaging about
six minutes
uh per per click-through rate so
um that's pretty i think that's actually
pretty good for a six-minute
view duration um one thing that i think
would be
a little bit interesting is to see like
when people are clicking on subscribe or
they're clicking to like your
your youtube channel or your playlist i
think those type of metrics would be uh
pretty interesting
but i'll kind of dive more into it once
you get into the deeper
um data set so again with the traffic
source from
playlists um i only have one playlist
basically having all my stuff
i know that some people do make their
own custom playlists and add my videos
onto it
which is really nice um but mostly i
think my traffic would come from the
titan tuesday project which is
you know essentially the this the
tuesday projects like series
um yeah so and then we have our
suggested videos so
based off of the suggested videos like
which one's getting suggested the most
and again we have the ufc dashboard
which for some reason
i think this is actually one of most my
most viewed videos
um which is kind of interesting because
i actually didn't really work
too hard on this video i was kind of
just doing this to mess around because i
saw
a kaggle data set um but i really didn't
think that there would be a
you know i think i thought ufc wasn't
that popular of a sport
especially with data and you know when i
think about data and sports i think more
about
baseball and football and stuff like
that but it gets a decent amount of
views and i think it's also a pretty
cool video too i just was a little
surprised that
i still get to d smaller views even
after uploading it
you know a few months ago and then again
um my most suggested video right now is
like the
beginner to advanced dashboards so we
can kind of see that
you know the suggested videos as this
weird
has a pattern of dashboards right so
creating and customizing
a simple our shiny dashboard etc um i
don't
i don't think that's yeah that's not in
my my video so it's
youtube is yeah okay so it's being off
of data science tutorials
cool i guess that makes sense so it's
youtube is definitely
i guess promoting more dashboard content
which could be
leading towards an increase of views of
my other videos
and then for youtube to search so we can
actually see you know
what are the search terms that are
relating to us to my videos
and it's what i would expect right so
tidy models tidy tuesday
are shiny shiny dashboard um i actually
made it i actually started changing my
videos where i would add those
like hashtags to my videos um let me
actually go to my
content so one of the things i was
reading um
just from like some youtube channels was
like you should always be adding
uh like hashtags because those are like
you know tags
that are a little bit more weighted um
so i
generally will always say hashtag tidy
tuesday is my intro because i have like
a template for it
but then i'll add more um hashtags to it
that i think are um you know related to
it so in this case it's like our shiny
hashtag tidyburst i actually think that
if i changed
if i swapped out uh tidybursted like
dashboard
or shiny dashboard it might improve my
my videos but maybe i'll actually have
to test that out so
there's not a lot of like um there's not
a lot of
uh tools for like a b testing uh or
comparing you know two types of videos
um which i wish youtube would offer but
they don't really have a good way to do
it
i have seen people do like different
tags so they'll have like
uh you know two sets of videos and
they'll put them in different like
playlists and they'll compare that
there's a compare option for that
but it's not as integrated and it's kind
of like a hacky way to do it
so hopefully um in the future they'll
have more like robust measurements
of comparing your your videos but
at the moment we can't do that that's
that might be a thing that i could start
maybe creating just you know creating a
simple little a b
test um app for like youtube analytics
i think that'd be pretty straightforward
um so maybe
maybe i'll actually do that i'm in the
future but um again
nothing too crazy for the youtube search
terms it's nothing surprising to me
at least when i was looking over the
stuff so now to actually go to
engagement which is
our third tab and this is the thing that
i really wanted to optimize off of
um it is kind of difficult for me to
figure out
you know how can i optimize you know
engagement or watch time
in my videos when i choose a lot of
different types of topics for my videos
um that i'm not sure you know how how my
audience would react to it
so for example um
like most of my um videos on like
on neural networks didn't really get a
lot of good watch time
um i i found that it still kind of
dropped off a lot
right now the computer vision i think
this one has a decent amount of watch
time
but like the auto encoder videos uh and
stuff like that
oh yeah i actually had a decent amount
of watch time a view duration
17 dude yeah some of my videos i found
that
you know for the amount of effort that i
put into it um didn't get
a lot of watch time um but one thing
that's cool is you can kind of see like
a survival curve of it
um where it's kind of um uh where it's
basically decreasing as it goes on right
until for the whole entire length of the
video but yeah so this is pretty
interesting
um we can see some spikes we have a huge
watch time and then we can see some dips
which might be a little bit
um interesting when but
again i don't really see any crazy dips
you know right here
i think generally people just didn't
want to watch this video right for that
long
um it's a pretty long video i think this
one
you know again this might have a lot of
like uh average percentage viewed but
these videos are pretty
short like some of these videos are
pretty short so it's kind of hard to
compare them
um directly but it's pretty interesting
stuff
um yeah so yeah i think
the key audience of audience retention
is pretty interesting
um but again it's something where i wish
we could have
a little bit more on granularity into
the youtube analytics but
i think it's still pretty good um it
kind of shows you
you know where the uh where they're
actually
i'm watching or when when they're
stopped when they're uh stopping
or uh when they stopped watching the
video so pretty good
um again and we can see that my watch
time again as like a time series
and you know uh see generally increase
our watch time in hours whenever
i release a video nothing too crazy
again
top top watch time in hours it's gonna
be my ufc dashboard video
it has a decent amount a lot of watch
time
which i'm pretty happy about um and
stuff like that and then like again
most of it is dashboards another one is
comparing tidy models
i think that this is like my breakout
video probably
or the video that is i knew was going to
get the most amount of views just
because
addie models was so like new when it got
released
you know it's been in like it's it's
been accessible for the past i think two
years
but then they just kind of started
saying that you know we're now doing
only tire models
carrot will not really be worked on
anymore so people started to
focus more on how to learn tight models
which was kind of my entire channel's
points or it's when my channel started
to form like some type of identity
around
um teaching tidy models so and then we
have
improved model train times oops
um i think that's a little interesting
because i
i think this video maybe is a little
clickbaity for some people
where um the the methods to improve it
is more about like
reducing the amount of parameters that
test but i still i still think it's a
pretty good video to be honest
um and then again i have a top playlist
i have a title tuesday project i have a
data science playlist that i kind of
have as
you know just some excess videos if i
want to watch during like a lunch break
or
i'm just something that i i think i
might use but i'm not sure if i'll
um actually get to it and have like a
random meme videos that
i think is kind of funny that some
people clicked on it even though it's
like 24
but these video or random videos i think
about is not about data science they're
just funny videos like the show my
friends
so i think that's pretty funny that um
some there's you know there's probably
like two or three people that watched it
um again and then we can see like the
top end screen element types
so clicks per end screen or best for
viewer playlist subscribe
um i wouldn't expect it to be that high
but i think i'd like to get
when the goals maybe for my channel is
to actually increase
um again i obviously want to increase
watch time but i want to be able to like
basically increase the amount of like
end screen end screen clicks so
hopefully like i want to make videos
that like more people watch the entirety
of where they get to the end screen
um which will be something where i
probably will have to focus more on
you know having a more concise topic um
or like a shorter video that has a more
concise topic where it's not
as imp improv like why i don't do like
improvisational stuff
it's more of a very focused uh
you know um stat quest style video
and then for audience um unique viewers
ad reviews per viewer
subscribers my subscribers is down by
one percent i'm not gonna really
sleep over that um average views per
viewer
i think that's pretty good um i think as
long as like above
you know like two i think that's fine
because that way
if someone comes to my videos i'm gonna
always click on another video
on on average you know that could be
just you know view like one out of five
viewers
clicks on like a lot of videos who are
really interested in data science or who
really
uh wants some help in data science so
obviously this could be
a little bit different it's not showing
like the distribution is just a raw
average
but um it is something that i think is
pretty useful to look at
unique views i'm not that interested in
looking at
unique viewers to be honest i would
rather have more recurring viewers who
are watching my videos than
than than a lot of unique viewers who
only go to my channel like once
right so i'd rather have an increased
average views per viewer than an
increase in unique viewers right
and then we have like when your viewers
are on youtube i think this is
interesting
um because i've noticed most of my
most of the people who subscribe to my
channel and comments
are not totally based in the united
states a lot of them come from like
india
um uh and stuff like that a lot of
people on who contact me on linkedin
are definitely not from america they're
from like asia
um africa etc uh which i think is really
cool to be honest to have
like a global um audience
so i think with your viewers are on
youtube on what the time
i i really don't know what i would do
because
the times that they have right here if
it's like i guess comparatively to my
time
is not something that's really viable
like um especially since i'm posting
mostly on
tuesdays because i think that's the tidy
tuesday so me i just
you know upload at like 7 ish p.m on a
tuesday
um generally i'll record the video maybe
a day early or even two days earlier or
even the day
but i try to get it out you know at 7 pm
on a tuesday
and then we have the subscriber bell
notification which i actually have not
i didn't realize that was here so
10 of my subscribers have the bell
notification
i think that's pretty high i would say
that's pretty high
so that would probably be why i have a
pretty stable amount of views is you
know to get the notification
uh so that's pretty interesting um again
now we can see our
watch time for subscribers 56 of my
viewers
aren't subscribed maybe i'd like to
increase my subscribed
um percentage but i'm not you know i'm
not
uh that worried about that i think this
again
i wouldn't expect um the majority of
viewers to be
like subscribed because i don't have
that many subscribers
um agent gender so
i think it's a little problematic for
you know the majority of my viewers 99
of my viewers are male
uh when we're talking about data science
i think that's kind of a problem in data
science itself
um i don't really know how i would
fix that i i'm not really sure um
i don't plan on like having a co-host or
even
really sharing other people's videos on
my channel i think this channel is
pretty small
and i don't think it would really add
that much value to it um
so um definitely something that's a
little odd i think
i would have it kind of expected just
because i think data
in computer science is definitely a male
dominated field
um but i don't know i think that's a
little odd
as for the age i think this is pretty
straightforward um i was pretty much
expecting this
uh you know 25 year olds you know a
little bit older excuse more on the
older end than the younger end
i'm a little bit more surprised i guess
um there's not as many
college you know 18 like was it 19 to
22 year olds or 23 year olds um
but again i think most people are like
grad students or augmented professionals
uh so again that's not something that
really surprised me at all
um subtitles languages i i don't
even think i really try to do subtitles
and languages
uh so i don't like i mean i don't really
care about this to be honest even though
like
i'm sure that there are some i'm sure a
lot
of some of my viewers you know english
is not their primary language
and i talk pretty fast and i don't
enunciate very well
but i i mean i don't think i'd really
change anything on my
presentations because it's not something
that i i would rather
you know prioritize to be honest um
and then my demographics most of its
united states but
22 percent as the united states so like
70
you know like 70s what seven percent
are not the united states or unknown i
think that's pretty interesting so
um that definitely shows that i have a
pretty global audience it's not just
united states people
so this is the basic summary of the
actual
um analytics tab what's actually cool is
you can go in to like see
more and then we can get all this data
right and this is where we can kind of
get into
you know what was going on so one things
that i should probably look at
is maybe um view let's do
let's do like impressions right so which
which
um channel like you know which video you
have the most
um impressions and they have it where
it's like you know each
each little row is a video we have their
watch time
subscribers gained uh impressions etc
and we can also add things so you know
we have
what is it subscribers we can do um
let's see
let's go to um where is it
like average view duration we have our
average view duration
our impressions so filter it out we can
say like okay like
um what's here can we yeah
how do i so yeah um it's pretty
interesting stuff like this
um one thing we can say is like okay
which which video
landed to be the most amount of
subscribers right so the creating a ufc
dashboard
landed me like nine subscribers or
whatever in the past 28 days
we'd also do maybe like the last 365
days or actually
a better way to do is be 2020
and then we can see like okay which
videos landing has the most amount of
subscribers right let's just take
the first five and get some type of
inference of
you know what what are the videos that i
should be making
um that uh would gain gave me a lot of
subscribers so there's like how to
create functions
um computer vision t-sne with tidy
models
adding models with our shiny uh ufc
dashboard with
a shiny dashboard and then comparing
tidy models with carrot
so these are just you know pretty simple
videos about the overall basics
of a r um i don't think i can make like
they're pretty uh separate from each
other like they're either talking about
like tidy models
functions dashboards etc
which is kind of a good cluster that i
think i think my channel kind of focuses
on
already so we can also go to say um
traffic source which i thought was an
interesting thing where you can go to
you know uh what is it where is the uh
um you can click on like external
and we can see our you know where are we
getting our our views from these
external sources
by google search um which they i guess
they took off the
they took off the search terms for it
which i think is kind of a bad idea but
we can also go back to traffic source uh
we can go to
suggested videos and see which
suggested videos are my videos located
on
so we can see uh what is it we can
probably go by impressions
and then we can see okay most of it's
probably from my own videos but then we
have
you know this video which is uh what's
which one is it
i think it's uh uh which is a julia
silky video right so
sometimes my videos are getting paired
up with julius silgi i think this one's
from the actual creator of rsr
um which is hadley wickham so we can see
that we have some videos or some
channels that we are kind of like
sharing the market of our you know data
science development
uh which are the people that i would
expect it to be honest like i know
a lot of my videos kind of are centered
around kind of like julia silly's style
video
or david robinson i'm actually a little
bit more surprised that i don't see
um any david robinson videos on here
but uh that that might be because he
makes more
um generic um titles for his videos so
that might be why um let's see here
let's go to let's let's see if there's
anything else
go to subscription source and go to
youtube search
oh oops you can't do that you uh
okay so there's not enough data on it
but we can actually maybe we can do a
um like i'm trying to think about maybe
what we could do for a uh
um an overall like views or subscribers
so
maybe i wanted to like forecast um
some forecast how do i if i wanted like
forecast my own subscribers that would
be kind of a useful thing to do
um because it seems like it's it's
somewhat cyclical we can maybe do like a
weekly subscriber
okay maybe maybe i actually couldn't but
uh it's something where you can see
um you know right when i start making my
videos and then we can see that
you know there's some spike so right
here
why did i gain 17 subscribers in the
um on october 14th so maybe we can go
back to there
and go to was october 14th
oh yeah i'm going to do a weekly thing
so in this case you know it came from um
where did it come from
so yeah it came from just like you know
a few videos we can all see
right here um you know most of my a lot
of subscribers from
tidy models uh with carrot computer
version with titan house etc
um let's here what else can i look at
yeah so i think that's basically it for
this video i don't know it's actually
this video is pretty long but
um i'll compile what i think are pretty
interesting metrics
um on um in a data set and i'll put it
on my github and put it in the link
below
so uh i just wanted to thank everyone to
uh for subscribing
to my channel um i think since next week
will be
like new year's i'll probably do maybe a
shorter video
um maybe another no code video just
because i'm gonna be spending time with
family this weekend
um and doing um some you know personal
stuff
so hopefully i'll see you guys next week
and tidy on